if you want to add email functionality
to your application this is the course
Craig Dennis has created some of our
most popular courses and he's back to
teach this course he's going to start
all the way back at the invention of
email and by the end you'll know how to
make your apps and emails using multiple
programming languages and
[Music]
libraries hey there I'm Craig and I'm a
developer I'm assuming that you're here
because you want to add or you've been
asked to add email functionality to an
application that you're working on this
is one of those things where you're like
of course adding email functionality
makes a ton of
sense wait how do I do that maybe you
got asked to send a confirmation email
when someone buys something on your site
this is called transactional email or
maybe you're trying to personalize your
marketing emails with actual user data
from the database email provides the
ability to track how receivers interact
with your message
which opens up a very powerful analytic
solution that you can use to help guide
your business now any way you look at it
email is an important part of the
applications that we build so
understanding how it works as well as
what its limitations are will greatly
help you throughout your career everyone
uses email email is one of those things
that we developers often take for
granted and as you're about to see there
is a lot that goes into making it work
properly in fact a popular saying is
this sending email successfully is more
art than science in this course we're
going to take a deep dive into email
we'll take a look at both the art and
the science now I'm going to do my best
to make this course fun and interesting
I'll start off by showing a little bit
of its history I think the only way to
truly understand its current state is to
take a quick stroll through its
Evolution as a technology there's also
quite a bit of drama in the past so if
you're into that sort of thing it's
going to get a little
the email world comes with a smattering
of acronyms now you and I both know that
those letters can make you feel
overwhelmed
AF my kids use that I think it stands
for absolutely frustrating and well I
don't like feeling overwhelmed and y'all
don't either right where' everybody go I
guess that return to office email ended
up in the spam folder this course isn't
going to be very code heavy I'll show
you some code examples and I'll point
you where to learn more about what you
find particularly interesting we'll also
take a look at some suggested approaches
and peruse our way through some email
apis I'll also explain what that means
if that's new to you throughout this
course I'm going to refer to the notes
they're attached to this video and I
will point you in that direction when
there's more to learn I'd love for you
to get in the habit of checking things
out there I'll document in there
anything that's different from my right
now to your right now basically it's
going to be a pretty great resource for
you you during and after this course
sound good okay so to kick things off
I'd like for you to try and imagine a
time before email even
existed like all great inventions it's
hard to imagine a time before that
invention was created like how did we
even survive without it email is
definitely one of those right I mean how
did we communicate before that did we
just call each other Well turns out yeah
we did do that quite a bit there were
lots and lots of phone calls in the
office World there is this concept
called inter office mail and you would
send physical documents in large
envelopes to specific co-workers in the
office there was a whole mail room and a
delivery system and they would manually
deliver these documents to employees
inboxes which were actually physical
boxes that you put mail in in
box often times your job as an employee
was to sign off on the document that you
received received and then forward it on
along to the next person some documents
even required signatures and if you
needed to keep a copy there was a
technology called carbon copy where you
would write through the page and it
would appear on the attached page of
course that carbon copy initials are CC
pretty cool right so you can imagine
that's what happened someone took this
already working inner Office Mail system
and digitized it or made it more
electronic electronic mail if you will
email for short there is actually a
Patent filed for the concept of email as
we know it and it was created by are you
ready for this a 14-year-old boy at MIT
his name was Shiva audai and it's super
impressive at how many Concepts his
project introduced that are still with
us today he wanted to create a system
that anyone could use and I'd say he
succeeded I mean my grandfather had an
email email address now one of the
reasons that you might not have heard of
this 14-year-old before is because of
some drama there's some conflicting
opinion on what an email actually means
let's go back a little bit before 1978
when this program was conceived remember
this was before the home computer was
readily available so many programmers
spent their time using a Mainframe think
of it kind of like the cloud a shared
computer that somewhere else would
execute your code it became necessary to
communicate with other users of the
system so there was a bit of a super
early instant messaging going on they
send a message hey there dude I need to
get some Cycles on the the main frame
you dig and the other programmer respond
with go for it I just wrapped up check
you on the flip side I'm not sure how
they spoke but I'd imagine it was
something like this without emojis or
anything those messages worked great but
they only functioned while both parties
were online so a way to capture messages
into a place that the party could pick
up later when they logged in was created
arpanet is known as the predecessor to
the internet that we all know and love
it consisted of a series of machines
that were connected together through a
network a software developer named Ray
Tomlinson created a way to send a
message to other connected computers he
called it s message or send message if
you put the missing letters back in the
way he did this was by using the at sign
to separate the user from the computer
Tom Lon is often noted as the
grandfather of the email because of this
cross computer messaging system and very
specifically for making use of that at
sign what was that symbol even used for
before who knows here's where the drama
comes in now often times Tomlinson is
credited as the Creator even though as
we heard the 14-year-old Shiva created
and patented the concept and as we can
see added more of the familiar inner
office parallels to our email world as
we know it now Shiva and and Ray have
had a lifelong beef and I'll put more in
the notes for those of you who are into
that sort of thing I can think of one
fantastic way of saying this I think
that my new husband Dr Shiva Ador the
inventor of email that was television's
own Fran dresser she was married to
Shiva for a little bit and she
definitely convinced me the popularity
and Rapid adoption of the email esque
application on arpanet is argued to have
laid the path for the creation of the
internet what it definitely did was
start another beef one that is so big it
has its own Wikipedia page called the
protocol Wars and while fascinating as
well I'll leave that to you to dig into
on your own time let's take a look at
the winners of that war here in just a
bit as we know that at sign was super
important it's almost like a right of
passage to using the internet and I'm
sure we can all remember remember our
first email address mine was very
ominous sounding Craig 2000 aol.com what
was yours let me know in the comments
let's take a quick break and let all
that history seep in but when we come
back let's take a look at how that
important at sign works today in the
modern
[Music]
internet
an email address contains two parts on
the left side of that Infamous at symbol
is the username and on the right side is
the domain name now the way the email
finds its way to you is by making use of
that domain name portion the way it's
able to do that is with DNS or domain
name system servers that are on the
internet have an IP address I IP stands
for Internet Protocol now we'll dive
into protocols here in a bit an IP
address traditionally is four numbers
between 1 and 255 separated by periods
the web browser uses DNS to find the web
server that hosts the web page that
you're attempting to view that URL
contains the domain name of the place
that you're looking at a common analogy
that's used to explain this is a little
dated for years we've been teaching it's
like you know it's like the phone book
you know you look up the name and then
you get the phone number but when was
the last time you ever even used the
phone book let's try this one on for
size you can search for a restaurant in
your Maps application and it Returns the
latitude and longitude for you as well
as term by term directions it translates
the name of the place that you're
looking for into map coordinates DNS
does a similar sort of thing it uses the
domain name to look up the IP address of
the server you're requesting the way
this works is that the owners of a
domain must must create DNS records that
associate their domain name with the
server's IP addresses and I say servers
here because they're can be multiple and
we've been talking about web servers but
there's also email servers so what
happens is that the domain owners add
what is known as an MX record a Mail
Exchange record or records actually you
can have multiple MX records and you can
prioritize them so that they get checked
for the user in order now with thing to
remember is that these early days
websites were not full-blown
applications like we have these days
these sites were just kind of like
informational Billboards they were
definitely a far way away from the
concept of a web-based email program
like Gmail now what these early email
adopters were using were called email
clients they were actual applications
that ran on your computer and they're
still around today what you the user of
the email client would do was to
configure your domain and then you could
use it to send and receive messages in
early cases messages were downloaded to
your computer and stored there locally
which of course caused problems later
when you got a new computer but we
weren't there yet we were here You've
Got Mail AOL would send an actual CD ROM
in the mail and you'd install it and it
included a mail client and we were so so
excited about being able to communicate
with each other these clients would use
the domain name to find the mail
Exchange
but then what great question and I'm
glad you asked it's time that we dive a
little bit into the winners of the
protocol Wars a protocol is a set of
agreed upon rules and they aren't just
limited to technology we have them in
real life too for instance if we're
meeting each other for the first time
and I stick out my hand the protocol
that us humans have established is that
you would put your hand in mine and we
would make a tight squeeze and we would
move it up and down right a handshake
it's kind of weird when you think about
it but a protocol nonetheless now it'd
be really strange if I put my hand out
for you to shake it and then you did the
Chicken Dance I mean I'd probably
appreciate you doing that but you will
for sure be breaking the protocol that
we have unspoken set up here let's do
another one how about the way that we
send actual mail like through the post
office now the protocol as I understand
it is this I put the contents in an
envelope and and on that envelope I
write your name and address and I also
put my return contact info in the corner
I put a stamp I drop this in the mailbox
and some post office hero comes and
picks it up it finds its way to you you
get it and you're like oh hey this is
for me and oh look it's from Craig I
wonder what it is we just successfully
ran a real life mail protocol stale mail
though it's not what we're here to talk
about what we're here to talk about is
the electronic version of that how did
we possibly enable everyone to be able
to start sending emails any
guesses if you guessed a well-defined
protocol you got it as the internet that
we know in love was being conceived it
became clear that in order to make it
open and extensible it was going to need
some standards and the way that these
standards came into being was by some
pretty clever group brainstorming a
memorandum called an RFC or a request
for comments was created and that had a
proposal and it was discussed by a group
of people interested in building a
stable and secure internet this group
that I'm talking about specifically here
is the ietf the internet engineering
task force which I think sounds like a
group of superheroes and I guess in
reality they truly are I know I owe my
career and most of my knowledge to their
early enablement of these ideas there
are multiple of these superhero groups
the internet Cinematic Universe if you
will that weigh in on these rfc's and
after they're approved they become known
as Internet standards now this RFC
process brought us some of the greatest
hits we're hanging out in one right now
check out your browser's address bar the
address starts with HTTP that's
hypertext transfer protocol and it was
introduced as an RFC and it became an
internet standard these are pretty
detailed and I find them quite
fascinating I love learning this history
but I know that's not why you're here
check the notes if I just nerd sniped
you so the internet standard that I'd
love to dive into here is an early hit
number 10 the one that enabled us to
send email SMTP or simple mail transfer
protocol you might not agree that it is
exactly simple but it is the defacto way
to get your mail transferred now
conceptually you have a sender and a
receiver they introduce themselves and
do a handshake oh hey just like us it's
a plain text protocol which means you
can kind of read it with a little more
information that there's a set of SMTP
commands and Status codes that can come
back in response they help you build the
envelope and explain what it is that
you're trying to send and to whom if
you're feeling brave you can actually
make use of this through a tool like
telnet which will allow you to
communicate with a remote server SM TP
is the internet standard used on the
sending side but there are also
protocols that allow mail clients to
retrieve the email from their mail
server pop or post office protocol often
now called POP 3 which is the current
version helps you as a reader of the
email receive a copy of it from your
serers side mailbox these days it's hard
to imagine but there was actually a time
when we weren't always able to be online
now this protocol enables you to
download messages from your mail server
to your local mailbox you wanted this so
that you could deal with them when you
were offline now original temps here
actually removed the message from the
mail server after it was downloaded to
the user's client side application
nowadays this can cause some issues
because we access our email from
multiple devices and things can get out
of sync which leads us to IMAP or the
internet message access protocol this
allows for better synchronization and
internal messaging and while you
probably aren't here to learn about the
receiving side of things you will see
both pop and IMAP quite a bit in the
space now I don't want you to feel like
you need to be able to explain how these
work without looking them up but I do
want you to recognize them when you see
them you'll encounter these in
documentation and now you should have a
basic understanding of what they are
remember if you ever want a refresher
check the notes for more info so now we
have all the these wonderful programs
anyone who implements the SMTP protocol
can send a message you can actually even
do this dance from the command line on
your computer or directly from
code and then of course the reason we
can't have nice things the Bad actors
showed up you guessed it it's time to
talk about spamming and
spoofing earlier when I asked you to
drop your first email address into the
comments I bet you had a weird feeling
about doing that something along the
lines of if I put this in here I'm
pretty sure I'm going to get so many
emails that I don't want now as you know
we call those emails the ones that you
don't want spam why would we do this who
wouldn't want this delicious stuff
right even though this feels like some
sort of advanced prop dad joke the term
that we use for emails that we don't
want is actually rooted in this meat in
a can well sort of the British comedy
troop Monty Python had a bunch of famous
sketches and one of their most absurd
involves a person attempting to order a
meal and they notice that everything on
the menu had spam in it and that person
asks everyone anything without spamming
it well a Spam egg sausage and spam
there not got much spam in it and asks
why can't you have egg BAC and spam and
sausage that's got spam in it not as
much as spam make sausage and spam look
could I ask egg bacon spam and sausage
without the spam because everything has
spam spam and more spam eventually
Vikings show up and Chaos
[Applause]
[Music]
ensues and Chaos did UE on the email
front too spam was everywhere those
well-defined protocols worked really
really well at connecting people and Bad
actors as we call them now saw this as
an opportunity to communicate what they
were selling and our inboxes were just
bombarded with offers for quite
literally everything there were email
lists that were for sale and boy if you
got on one of those lists you got so
much spam those lists are still for sale
by the way don't buy them it might sound
like a good idea but it is a very very
bad idea but in the beginning it's
important to remember that there were no
real standards or even etiquette at the
time so everyone was probably a little
guilty of over sending messages that
receivers didn't really want there were
all sorts of lawsuits like people people
actually got arrested check the notes
for more there's so much drama right
finally in 2003 the FTC got involved and
get this the ACT is called controlling
the assault of non-solicited pornography
and marketing or can spam for short I
see what you did there FTC now this act
applies to all commercial email messages
not just bulk ones the non-compliant
penalties can be pretty hefty up to
$50,000 these introduced some rules that
are pretty straightforward and really
made a difference in the amount of spam
that we were fighting let's talk through
them really quick don't use false or
misleading Header information now all of
the information on your email envelope
must be accurate and identify the person
or business as the center don't use
deceptive subject lines be careful with
the clickbait you have to make sure that
your messages is about what the subject
claims identify the message as an ad you
need to let people know that you're
sending an ad there are best practices
here and there's more in the notes tell
recipients where you're located you have
to provide a valid street address tell
recipients how to opt out a receiving
future marketing email from you you have
to let your users tell you that they
don't want any more messages like the
one that you just sent you need to do
this again best practices are in the
notes remember that subscribers and
members can opt out of Marketing emails
too if you have an app that makes use of
subscriptions and memberships you have
to also make sure that they can opt out
now this one can be a little tricky but
don't forget to let them not receive the
emails and honor opt out requests
promptly this can get a little tricky
too if you offer opt out it has to work
for at least 30 days and you have to
honor it within a minimum of 10 days
monitor what others are doing on your
behalf the law makes clear that even if
you hire another company to handle your
email marketing you can't contract away
your legal responsibility to comply with
the law the can spam Act made a huge
dent in the emails being sent but spam
still maintained a very impressive
sometimes upwards of 70% of all email
traffic now luckily for those of us with
email addresses the spam percentage is
constantly dropping our email providers
are making it harder and harder for the
Bad actors to get those bad emails to
land in your inbox can you do me a favor
I want you to go and look at your spam
folder just take a quick look at in
there go ahead and pause me and then
take a peek and then come back to
me pretty gross right now however did
you see in there there's probably some
messages that were incorrectly marked
spam providers have done the best that
they can but sometimes wanted messages
actually end up in there as someone who
is considering getting email running for
your application you don't want this to
happen to you we'll talk through some
best practices through the rest of this
course of how to get your message into
the Inbox and out of the spam folder
this is called deliverability and is
truly an art form now one of the first
points in the can spam act talks about
not faking the sender unfortunately SMTP
doesn't provide authentication so it's
relatively easy to pretend to be someone
else if we flip back to our snail mail
example I can swap out my return address
to whatever I want and maybe that make
you want to open it well I can do the
the same thing with my email envelope
pretending to be someone you are not is
called spoofing and it's a bummer the
good news is there are ways of handling
this and employing suggested methods
will greatly help you with your
deliverability journey let's take a
quick break and when we come back let's
take a look at some of these
authentication
mechanisms
m
h
[Music]
H as you can imagine it's important to
the receivers of your emails that they
can identify that the email is actually
from you as more and more spoofing
happened technology was added to give
you a little more power in making this
dream happen for many years these
techniques were known as a best practice
these days however they're basically
slowly becoming required changes are
happening in 2024 that will make all
senders start sending properly
authenticated emails to be considered
trustworthy the way this works is with
surprise a group of more acronyms I
apologize I know that there's a lot in
this space now I want you to approach
these the same way I don't want you to
feel like you have to understand them
completely but it will certainly benefit
you to be able to recognize them you'll
find these acronyms and blogs and drop-
down menus and function parameters often
without any explanation whatsoever and
yes I realize that the more pedantically
focused Learners may say that these are
actually initialisms and non acronyms
but I say any initialism can be an
acronym if you try hard enough SPF or
spiff stands for a cinder policy
framework it can be set up by adding an
additional DNS record for your mail
server this specifies who can send
messages down to a specific IP address
this makes it way more challenging for
spoofers to try and manipulate your
envelope dkim or domain Keys identified
mail is similar to SPF you publish your
public key as a DNS record but dkim adds
an additional layer you sign each and
every message the receiver can use the
signature to validate that the message
has not been tampered with most male
clients provide a way for you to see the
original message as it was sent for
instance in Gmail I can open up the
additional menu and choose show original
here you can see if the SPF check passed
and also what happened with the dkim and
if you want to dig you can peep at all
the headers that came
across DeMark or domain-based message
authentication reporting and conformance
came on the scene in 2015 and it moves
to further take on spoofing issues it
extends both SPF and dkim to allow the
receiving email server to authenticate
the incoming message a DNS DeMark record
is added and in it it defines how you
would like to handle any message that
didn't meet the specification it can
also specify how strict things need to
be email domain owners can get a daily
report of what messages failed to pass
more in the notes on dmart again
coming very soon everyone will need to
adhere to these to be able to send to
Gmail and Yahoo now the advice is that
every other provider is going to follow
their lead so make sure that you check
the notes for how to embrace these email
authentication
protocols you are now armed with the
foundational knowledge that you need to
start sending emails there is a lot that
goes into making your email Adventure
successful and I'm so glad that you've
dipped your toes in its history the
terminology and and the challenges you
have a pretty firm handle now on the
what and the why in the remainder of
this course we're going to focus on the
how now remember this how includes both
science and art we're going to focus a
little bit heavier now on the science
portion but keep at the top of your mind
as we talk through things I want you to
have excellent email deliverability I
want you hanging out in the Inbox and
avoiding the spam folder otherwise
what's it all for there's a best
practice surrounding email
deliverability that I love always ask
yourself this am I sending the right
message to the right person at the right
time with the right frequency now this
question applies both to the
transactional emails that you send as
well as the marketing messages that you
might be considering you are essentially
building a reputation and you want to
make sure that you make a great first
and longlasting impression with your
users and email providers all right
let's check out some
code I've got great news for you you are
not alone as is the case in most things
that you'll find along your coding
Journey someone has been here before and
if you're lucky they've already written
most of the code for you email is pretty
awesome for this actually there's so
much email code written for you already
that it's almost hard to choose these
packaged up code bundles are typically
called libraries someone has already
taken the time to follow those email
protocols that we talked about and it's
been all abstracted away for you python
Embraces a batteries included approach
which means there's a module included
for email you'll see here that you can
create an email message and then send it
using the SMTP live module good thing
you've heard about the simple mail
transfer protocol right one thing to
point out here is that you can also use
an SMTP command to encrypt your emails
it's called start TLS or startles if
you're feeling cute I've dropped the
information in the notes about how to
use
TLS if you don't have access to an SMTP
server check out the notes for some
ideas on how to get your hands on some
thanks to those well-defined internet
standards you can pretty much guarantee
that every programming language is going
to have something similar check the
notes for some guidance on how to find
examples in your
language it'll probably help you to
imagine how you might end up using this
in your day-to-day coding Journey most
applications that have users
authenticate have some pretty common
workflows for example there's almost
always a flow to handle when a user
forgets their password typically what
you do here is ask the user for their
email you check that it exists in your
system and if it does you send an email
with a password reset link you can
imagine how you might do that right in
your controller you check the submitted
email address to verify and then you'd
craft an email message and send it using
your library
it's pretty critical that this specific
email makes it to your user quickly you
don't want this email to end up in the
spam folder they'll be expecting it and
if they don't get it they're probably
going to quickly give up on whatever it
was that they were trying to accomplish
in your application and we don't even
really need to imagine the overarching
business not having users being able to
log into your system as well bad for
business while this inline solution will
work it's probably a good idea to get
involved with how your marketing
messages are being sent out the IP
address that you send messages from has
its own reputation a best practice worth
exploring is to keep the senders that
you use for transactional messaging
separate from your marketing senders
it's also not a great idea to just start
sending a bunch of emails all at once as
that could introduce some suspicion it's
best to take some time and build up your
reputation before sending bulk messages
this is called IP warmup up remember
that the email providers are doing their
best to stop spam before it reaches
their customers you need to make sure
that they trust you there is a lot that
goes into this email deliverability and
there are entire companies who make it
their business to make this happen for
you let's take a quick break and then
let's take a look at some email API
[Music]
services
application programming interfaces or
apis provide the applications that you
build with new functionality they
abstract away complexity and give you a
straightforward way to achieve the
impossible now if apis are new to you
check the notes I have a whole course on
them specifically for
beginners sometimes a challenge is so
big that an entire company forms around
the problem and it provides an API to
help us developers solve those problems
email is one of those challenging
problems not only is the landscape
complex but it's ever evolving you
definitely will benefit from having an
entire team of people focus on your
solution there are multiple email apis
and each one of them have their own
strengths and weaknesses one of my
favorite ways to find new products is to
use GitHub awesome lists there are tons
of lists of solutions out there and
folks maintain those lists so here's the
one for emails now traditionally when
presented with these options I've always
chosen syrid when my current employer
twilio and syrid merged it was a
pleasant surprise and I'm so stoked that
we have an email channel for all of our
applications my appreciation for the
work they do has only gotten stronger
but everyone's needs are different so
please don't just take my word for it
peruse around and see what resonates
well with you there's something for
everyone
it might turn out that you don't even
want to choose an email API and you want
to roll your own code like we just saw I
do recommend taking the time to
familiarize yourself with the offerings
that are available to you they can
inspire you with ideas that you might
not have come up with before and
remember API companies always get better
there are teams of people making sure
that you get the most up-to-date
security and they assist you in
following the Ever Changing best
practices all those acronyms the new
protocols that might crop up they've got
their eyes on them there will be
reporting and monitoring you can pretty
much guarantee that due to the beauty of
competition the service is going to try
and be the best so you're always going
to be getting new features now most
likely they'll guide you through how to
do the more detailed DNS things I don't
know about you but DNS record
manipulation for some of the bigger
companies that I've worked for is not
something that I've been allowed to
touch they don't want me in there and I
totally get it no offense
some of these email apis prepare the
requests that you need to make and email
them to your system administrator I
can't tell you how much I appreciate
this feature good email apis will
provide ways for you to separate your
transactional and marketing messages and
guide you there as a best practice while
you now know that's why that's important
it might not have been clear to those
just getting started some companies even
have deliverability experts that will
work with you if you're having trouble
deciding on which to choose check out
their blogs are they publishing the
information that will help you in the
art portion of emails do they have the
science in place to meet your needs a
feature that you'll want to take a close
look at is templating we haven't really
chatted about this yet but you can use
HTML in your email messages this really
helps with design but producing an email
that looks good and works on all those
clients it's really tricky the HTML that
you can use is limited and it has all a
lot of gotas especially in those client
side applications now a good email API
will offer you a way to edit and create
beautiful emails most of these providers
allow for some sort of way to maintain a
list of your contacts remember the more
engaged your contacts get the better
keeping well-maintained contact list
really helps to ensure this also you'll
probably want to have some help dealing
with
unsubscribed remember those rules of the
can spam a good email a Pi will help you
adhere to those rules and help you stop
from making mistakes it's in the
company's best interest and yours to
keep your reputation healthy they want
you to be able to scale to send millions
of emails let them help you one of my
favorite analogies about using an API is
to think of it about like a package
delivery system like FedEx or UPS you
could of course get in your car with
your package and drive over to deliver
it in person now if the person doesn't
answer the doorbell you probably don't
want to just leave it there maybe you'll
come back later or give them a call
maybe maybe they want you to deliver it
to their office actually now eventually
you're going to get the package there
but probably not something you want to
do all the time I mean especially if you
have lots of packages you probably want
to use something more like a package
delivery service like a UPS or a FedEx
you know that they're the experts and
they have ways of getting your package
there no matter what they have worked
through the workflows and are reliable
in fact they'll even send status updates
as your package is in route to that
destination oh if you don't mind me
popping out of that analogy let's talk
about how rich the events that happen
are when you send an
email when an email gets sent there is
information that is most likely made
available to you via your email API of
choice now a common approach to this is
to use web hooks web hooks are like a
reverse API instead of you calling the
API the API calls you when the event
occurs now you write code that handles
it email has so many great events that
you can use to improve your
deliverability and your engagement
you'll see here these delivery events
like processed dropped delivered
deferred and bounced they're super handy
in building reporting tools you also
have super powerful engagement events
like open and click this information
here shows who they are and even what
they clicked now this could be super
helpful if you're trying to attract a
certain audience there's all sorts of
excellent information that you can
process and if your service provides it
you can actually see when people report
your email as spam or if they choose to
unsubscribe now most likely your service
provides a way to manage this but these
can be additionally helpful I love
seeing what people build with these
events it really helps you to build
healthy and reputable email campaigns
now take a moment and think about how
this might benefit you in what ever
brought you to this course in the first
place would it be helpful to track your
transactional message delivery what
about if you're thinking about sending
marketing emails wouldn't it be awesome
to be able to track which message is
landing the best you can test out all
sorts of things you could probably use
this data to answer the question am I
sending the right message to the right
person at the right time with the right
frequency now while I got your brain
activated let's take things one step
further so not only can you write code
to handle the events that happen when
you send a message some of these email
apis actually let you process incoming
messages I've seen some super cool stuff
built with this idea one of my favorite
implementations that I can think of of
all time is expensify I can email a
photo of a receipt into expensify it
receives my message processes the photo
using OCR or Optical Character
resolution and because it knows who I am
from my email address it can create an
expense report in a draft State filled
out with my expense item they send me
back a message with a link to the report
it's beautiful I think with the
approachability of AI these days we are
going to see more and more of these
inbound email-based applications now I
know it's out of the scope of this
course but I just wanted to share my
enthusiasm for it check the notes for
more information on this concept you did
it you made it to the end of the course
I hope you had a fun time and learned a
lot about the Art and Science necessary
to make email work for you this is a
journey and I can tell you already
you're off to a great start please keep
me posted on your progress I take your
feedback very seriously and I'd love to
hear from you please check the notes for
how to get in touch with me thanks so
much for hanging out and we'll see you
real
[Music]
soon
w